right good
evening everyone
uh welcome a warm welcome uh both
literally and metaphorically um to uh
particularly uh members of the public um
other members and uh members of the
executive and indeed officers tonight
and i'll just go through the emergency
evacuation announcement which uh we're
starting to become quite familiar with
but should we be required to evacuate
the building would you please leave the
building by the entrance doors to the
hall
continue straight on and exit the
building via the double doors on the
right to the car park which is the
assembly point
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings please do not
return to the building until given
permission to do so by council staff
and please note that the meeting is
being audio recorded
please switch off mobile
phones or turn them to silent please
members there are four microphones i
think there's probably only three now
but anyway four microphones
on the tables for use during the meeting
when i invite you to speak please wait
until there is a microphone in front of
you before speaking as microphones are
needed for the hearing loop and for the
audio recording please where possible
assist in passing microphones to each
other
and use the hand gel and antibacterial
wipes on the tables if you do not if you
do touch the microphones
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the constitution i
will ask for a show of hands for and
against recommendations and will then
ask for any abstentions so
here we go a take item agenda number one
and apologies for absence and
we've received apologies from
councillor simon smith who is in
isolation at the present time and
councillor webb
moving on to agenda item number two uh
non-members attending uh looking around
we've got uh councillors
uh james gooding councillors judy
gooding
councillor eileen gadsden um and uh who
else have we got councillor laureen shaw
councillor foster
have i missed anyone
right no
moving then on to item number three uh
minutes of the meeting held on the 10th
of june
members are the minutes agreed
thank you
item number four to receive declarations
of interest
are there any declarations of interest
members on the agenda
nope
questions on notice from councillors
agenda item number five and there are
none
and matters referred to the executive
and reports from other committees item
six there are none
which takes us on to
item seven the association of south
essex local authorities a seller and the
formalization of a joint committee
members you have a paper in front of you
which actually sets out i think
extremely well
the next stage in the
development of a seller
i have to say that
when i became leader which was about
this time last year
a seller for me was
an organization
that i recognized was at a stage an
evolutionary stage where
we needed to improve transparency
ensure that we were
communicating what the seller was doing
to certainly members mps and members of
the public
recognizing that the product that a
seller is
trying to deliver
is a sound product
but we did need to enhance communication
issue agendas now a seller was formed uh
under a memorandum of understanding in
january 2018
and it is a collaboration between the
south essex local authorities the sixth
south essex local authorities and essex
county council
and it is about delivering uh and
improving the quality of life for south
essex residents
by realizing the potential economic
potential
to realize
opportunities in terms of jobs
the economy as i say in in in south
essex
and to
highlight
for both leisure
and for jobs for homeowners
the economic potential that we have here
as i said my concern this time last year
was that there was a perception and i do
stress the word perception that meetings
were being held
in
some degree of secrecy they weren't in
fact in in secrecy but they used to be
held and then people would come out of
those meetings and no one would really
know what a seller was all about
what happened
around the time that i became leader but
not i think because of me becoming
leader was there was a growth bid that
was submitted on the
welcome councillor eves and we will log
you as a uh a visiting member thank you
very much indeed um
what happened on the 31st of july
last year 2020 was a growth bid and a
prospectus was
issued and submitted to
government central government
i have to say it was around the time
that
local government reform was being talked
about
and i think the whole agenda got rather
muddied
in terms of
local government reform and what a
seller was trying to achieve
local government reform uh safari's
central government is concerned fell off
the agenda because it has been deferred
postponed um but certainly it's
certainly not number one item for the
government at the present time
in the way it was being portrayed
but recognizing the need for a seller to
move on
the joint committee idea which is a
formal system of governance
was born because it was recognized that
for a seller to
survive and move on from the
collaborative approach
for it to
have a much more formal approach with
published agendas published minutes
a website uh communication
for it to be able to have a funding
stream it was very very important that
there was a form more formal arrangement
i have consistently said that the
product that a seller is trying to
deliver i believe is a good product and
there are five very clear high-level
strategic objectives set out within this
paper
and have been set out
in other papers
about what a seller is about
and the real emphasis moving forward
will be about delivery
but the reality is that you can't
deliver
without having a formal governance
system
and that is really what the joint
committee is all about
so having really sort of introduced um
the report
i'm going to ask the acting managing
director angela hutchings just to put a
little bit more meat on the bones in
terms of where we are with the seller
angela over to you
thank you councilor that's better
the five anchor programs that form the
body of work that a seller is now
planning to deliver are explained in the
report
they are a super fast digital
infrastructure program a technical
university for tertiary education and
skills across south essex
the south essex estuary park a green and
blue
infrastructure
that covers 53 000 hectares of space
across the entire sub-region
infrastructure and housing around were a
place-based partnership with homes
england
and the
potential investment of the thames
freeport
and the south of the county and the
bounce effect of that
regeneration piece and the impact
therefore on the local economy and the
potential for taking
and catalyzing that investment to
support
communities
to continue to develop a economy outside
of london
the
anchor programmes have now reached a
state of maturity
in where they are looking for further
investment from the private and from the
public sector
they have overlap and coalescence in
terms of delivering a whole place-based
solution
and so it's right now that the
governance should follow to enable
delivery of that pro of those programs
and the entire vision of the acella
prospectus
the joint committee is an established
model for doing so it enables
authorities to maintain their individual
sovereignty whilst coming together for a
common purpose they were
permitted by statute and as i say are a
common vehicle for this kind of
opportunity
it's particularly relevant for a seller
because what it does is it gives it
accountability and transparency
when you're looking for investment
whether that's from the public sector or
from the private sector having that
accountability enshrined is really
important to ensure that investors can
have security that the monies are being
properly spent and the public can be
assured that the monies are
being put towards the programs that are
being outlined
so the committee um is
proposed to be set up and each of the
seller authorities including essex
county council will have a seat on that
committee
the basic proposition is that it is one
authority one vote and that as part of
the sovereignty
main the maintenance of sovereignty no
decision can be made in respect of
rochford district that rockford district
is not a party to
so this is no cessation of um
sovereignty on our part and does not
take away from us any of the decisions
that we would make in the normal course
of business
there's no delegation of other powers to
this joint committee it's there purely
to oversee and provide accountability
and scrutiny to the delivery of the five
anchor programmes
thank you councillor
thank you angela and certainly appendix
one details the growth prospectus that
was submitted
last year
appendix ii
sets out the
joint committee agreement
and constitution proposed constitution
and appendix 3
sets out the direct benefits to rochford
albeit i think it's actually very hard
to do that piece of work because
actually it is the collective
opportunities that
a seller provides
to
south essex
so with that
members are there any any questions
counselor fd
thank you um uh angela mentioned in her
last bit of
her presentation um
7.6
practicalities of a seller joint
committee h with scrutiny would that be
our
review
because it says to use it's proposed
that scrutiny of a said it will take
place for each partner council's
existing process
that will be reviewed yes that's correct
yes the the committee itself provides an
over a small overview function in
relation to the administration of the
program but the performance of the joint
committee would be subject to the
overview and scrutiny arrangements of
each individual
authority all right okay thank you
thank you councillor fd any other
questions
no
i'm actually looking somewhere in the
documentation and i think it's the um
the
joint committee agreement and
constitution it does refer to the set up
being on the 1st of april 2021
well clearly that date has yet to be
agreed because we passed
that date so it won't be retrospective
it will be at a date um
to be agreed and i assume it will be
something of the order of something like
september um around that time but uh
september let's go for autumn and then
yeah yes i think that's right councillor
um
the uh decisions are taken by each
individual council so when all councils
have signed up to this then the joint
committee will be capable of being
properly constituted
okay if there's no other
questions or points to be made
um we will if we may move to the uh
decision which is outlined
at item one of the
reports
now
1.1
the executive notes the updates provided
in this report
can i take it that we note it
noted right okay
where are the recommendations and i will
read them out in a moment 1.2 1.3 and
1.4
um
i'm
with your agreement proposing to take
those on block but if i read them out
and then if there's any questions about
taking him on block we'll come back to
that but
1.2 reads to formally agree to become a
member of the association of south essex
local authorities as seller joint
committee in accordance with section 101
of the local government act 1972
to oversee a seller and provide enhanced
transparency and accountability in the
new delivery stage of its work
programmes
1.3 reads to approve the governance
arrangements
of the joint committee in accordance
with governing documents set out in
appendix 1
and 1.4
to appoint the leader of the council as
their representative on the joint
committee and to appoint the deputy
leader as a substitute member as set out
in the governing documents
i
just want to raise a question with a
monitoring officer appendix one
relates to the growth and recovery
prospectus i think it should be appendix
two
in recommendation 1.3
right i just noticed that so
with that minor amendment
members are you happy to take that on
block or do you want to vote on them
separately council ward
yes chairman um just a question on
it's uh 1.4
we're talking about the leader and then
the deputy leader as a substitute member
what happens if the deputy leader or the
leader cannot attend what is the
situation then
right i'm being told there is no
substitute then it will be tightly
defined under the tree is defined so
that's why i'm asking that specific
question as
there is an occasion where
i have been asked
to substitute
and now with maybe falling foul of this
agreement i i do realize council award
that uh it's particularly topical
because neither i as the leader can
attend next thursday's a seller meeting
which is still under the old
arrangements of the memorandum of
understanding
and neither can the
deputy leader due to work commitments so
i realize it's topical but it is
extremely rare that that situation will
occur uh and uh i think we've just got
to accept that in that situation rare
situation uh we will not be represented
but uh
meetings will be scheduled um probably a
year ahead um so it ought to be possible
for us to uh work our time just to
clarify that with you but nevertheless
thank you very much for making the point
right moving back to the recommendations
1.2 1.3
with that minor remember 1.4
um are we happy first of all take it on
block
yep okay and are we also uh agreeing uh
to those recommendations
agreed
lovely thank you
right if we can move on please to
item number eight
which is the parks for nature initiative
and delivery of grounds maintenance
and it's to consider the report of the
assistant director place an environment
providing a summary of the public
consultation on the parks for nature
initiative and seeking approval for
delivery of grounds maintenance in-house
with effect from december 2020
and at that point i will hand over to
councillor spurring initially
ably supported i'm sure by the assistant
director place and environment
council sparring thank you leader
well as it says this is a two-pronged
project basically
our contract with our grounds
maintenance
company latco expires at the end of
december this year and we need to put in
place
where we go when that contract expires
and we need to start doing that now
not only
is it necessary to to look after the
staff if we need to pee them over but we
also need to sort out various pieces of
heavy machinery that will be needed to
maintain maintenance ground maintenance
across the district
that being one aspect
um and in the report our various
financial assessments of the route ahead
why we should take
this off this service in in in
um but it also goes hand in hand with
the initiatives that we put out with
regard to parks to nature
um
which is in support uh
to the council's policy to try and make
the district carbon neutral by 2030.
we have
issued a consultation
um
i'm reliably informed that we've had
over 400 responses and 92 percent of
those were in favor of the proposals
that we outlined in that consultation
document
um
i think it's it's fair to say that we
have noticed over the last few years
the requirements for
uh organized sports event has
considerably reduced in the district and
while obviously there is the need for
large recreational spaces with people
using more and more uh
flat parkland for their recreation there
is also the scope to introduce
meadow land and trees
this is a combination that we've been
pursuing
we have
i think been to every ward
to
in conjunction with mr aldridge our open
space officer to highlight to counselors
the initial ideas what we what we
envisage
you know
if
we realize
in in the short term that there is
something not quite right well then we
can amend it it is grass we're not
talking about concrete in anything over
so we can make modifications it will be
ongoing
and i say that the two
items virtually go hand in hand
um it always also encompasses a bigger
project where we will be introducing
noticeables and highlighting what the
plans are for how we're doing things
we're also looking to replace benches
waste bins and put them in more
strategic places so that it's better for
our residents and more
economical for our staff to collect them
i think that's pretty much it uh leader
unless anybody's got any
any plans but we will this is being
rolled out as of now by and large but it
will take a year perhaps 18 months to
fully implement but we do anticipate
that there will be amendments needed
along the way or adjustments but uh
that's with regard to the parks and
nature and we will also
by the end of by
start the new year hopefully have all
our people and the necessary equipment
in place for our maintenance
that's it
thank you councillor spurring for that
comprehensive report i'm not sure
whether
assistant director you want to add
anything to it
i was just trying to click collect my
thoughts i think i think uh council
sparring has covered that quite
comprehensively um again only just to
express my my thanks um
to the contribution from um
various counselors that have met on site
to discuss
the sort of the finer detail some of the
site plans uh but a particularly
a particularly big thank you to accounts
of sparing as a portfolio holder i think
it's a real testimony to visit every
site on foot walk around every site
uh over in just a month's period i think
it's real dedication and the support's
been greatly appreciated by myself and
officers so thank you
but i'm happy to take any questions
council award thank you very much
chairman um i've just got one it's uh i
know that when we went around lodge ward
we noticed that the residents were very
pleased with what was going on
but there may be other areas where
there may not be as much contentment
how will we deal with that in feedback
if we get that
discontentment thank you
i think
to i think
we will
receive some
uh criticism
i don't doubt that it's new it's
different people don't always like
change
but
as i say
the people that have responded 92
supported the project i think there is a
mood in the country that we need to be
doing something to try and improve our
carbon footprint
and this is a positive step
if we find that
there are areas that we need to amend or
adjust
we can do it it will be an ongoing
learning curve for both us and residents
but i think ultimately
it will be beneficial for everyone but i
do anticipate yes there will be some
negativity along the line
okay thank you
thank you councilwood thank you accounts
for sparing any other points
okay um
well i just want to endorse uh the point
that the assistant director has made
i think the commitment and dedication by
you and your officers along with
the portfolio holder and individual
councillors has been commendable so
thank you very much indeed for that and
i would like to just stress and and
i think it would be
start to be easy to go through all of
these
pictures of individual areas and for it
forensically examine them and that is
not what tonight is all about because
that work has been done
but i would appreciate a commitment and
i think you've said it counselor
spurring that we are
flexible to community needs where there
may be conflict because what we do not
want to do in my opinion is find that we
compromise
good sites that are currently being used
for leisure
and we come into conflict uh with what
we're trying to achieve here so i think
there's got to be flexibility if we get
a community response to ensure that we
try and
seek some compromise to achieve both
what we're doing here but at the same
time meet the leisure and community
needs of the um of the specific
community
so we want we want to actually take the
community with us council speakers come
back later the fact that the the uh
grounds maintenance will be in-house
effectively makes it even easier for us
because it will be
mr mr hotten and mr aldridge who will
control and dictate where our staff will
be operating and how they will be
operating so all in all it will be a
more
joined up approach to what we're doing
right right well that's great to hear
because clearly this is also about
taking residents with us
in pursuit of achieving an objective
that
residents are also very keen for us to
achieve so
thank you very much so if there's no
further questions
no i will turn to the
decisions and
once again um
i'll read out 1.1
that the comments and summary of the
public consultation relating to the
parts for nature initiative be noted is
that noted
right and i'm going to ask you to raise
your hands because um i think it helps
our officers if we do actually raise our
hand rather than just mumble agreed so
we we will be taking 1.2 and 1.3 on
block if you agree
and 1.2 that the parks for nature
initiative be rolled out with change to
the grounds maintenance regime as
reflected in the proposal set out in
appendix one
and 1.3 that members approved to deliver
grounds maintenance in-house commencing
in december 2021
option one first of all do you agree to
taking those both together agreed i
agree agreed right
and can i uh have your agreement or
otherwise please raise your hand if you
agree
and that is unanimous
thank you very much indeed members for
that
we move to item number nine which is
residual waste arrangements to consider
the report of the assistant director
place an environment providing details
of the current waste tipping
arrangements for the rochford district
and setting out the joint procurement
arrangement that is to be undertaken
alongside neighboring authorities for
the transfer of residual waste during
the 2021-22
financial year
and um at that point i think we hand
over to you again councillor spurring
you're you're uh doing well tonight
thank you leader um
the the report that uh mr houghton has
has
is very comprehensive but also at times
very confusing
so i've asked him to give me a brief
note that hopefully in a very short
space
we'll explain the situation in real
layman's terms and if i may read that
out it may give you a gist of what it's
all about rochford district council have
a duty to collect the refuse and we are
referred to as a waste collection
authority
essex county council have the duty to
disclose can you just hold on second
council sparing
we did ask at the start that mobile
phones be put to silent or turned off
can uh
everyone make sure they are pleased
councillor sparring thank you essex
county council have a duty to dispose of
that waste and are known as the waste
disposal authority
essex as the waste disposal authority
can legally instruct rochford where to
dispose of the refuse i think these are
the critical points that people have got
us pick up on at the moment rochford has
been instructed to deposit the waste of
basilan
from the 1st of october we have been
told by essex to take the waste up to a
landfill site near colchester
essex will provide financial
compensation to rochford for journey
this payment is known as a tipping away
payment and is worth just over 23 pounds
per ton
this is
this is set non-negotiable payment
however the driving the refuse trucks
twice up a day up to colchester would
not be economic or logistically feasible
with half of the collection day
potentially being spent traveling along
the a-12
usually in these circumstances a waste
transfer station is used where the waste
is dropped off locally bulked up and
then hauled in large lorries in the case
up to landfill in colchester
soft marketing would suggest that
payments being offered by essex will
cover the cost of such a transfer and
haulage facility
in this it is in this facility that
roger proposes to secure a joint
procurement exercise with basildon and
castle point we'll all get their waste
up to colchester
really there isn't a viable alternative
but the long and short of it is that we
will work with our baseline and castle
point to form a local uh transfer point
and then that will be hauled up so that
basically
none of us have taken our refuge trucks
up to basil and up to colchester twice a
day
that's it in a nutshell leader
thank you councillor spurring for uh
simplifying a uh pretty complex report
as you say um
assistant director marcus hotten do you
wish to add anything
no i think it's pretty best to keep
trying to keep some of it simple i mean
i'd um my apologies for the complexity
of the report i'd actually rewritten
that at least twice and it still
confused me
um and so i realized for the best things
just i probably should just written it
as i say it um but
the details there if anyone requires you
to think it's a key thing as well
thank you very much indeed members any
questions on that item
councilor williams
okay uh thank you um
mr holton um can you confirm that you
you you're all comfortable
and happy that we'll be able to maintain
an efficient waste collection service
once this is implemented
i think we have a better chance of doing
so
in that there will be more certainty
over where the waste transfer facilities
are i think some of the some of the
challenge we've had uh for the last um
sort of six to 12 months is we've
they've been
a constant change of where we are
depositing waste which causes um a
challenge for the contractor so you you
know
you you um plan your routes or you try
and optimize your routes as to where
you're dropping the waste off to
as part of that journey so if you keep
changing where you're dropping the waste
off to then you end up having um
slack or overload on those routes so it
can only improve the situation
so that's a yes thank you well it's as
close as i'm going to say thank you very
much
thank you councillor williams
any other points before we moved council
aboard
thank you
leader um i just wondered this may not
be within here if i may it's within uh
using waste for energy was there any
movement from essex whatsoever
on the proposals to actually use that
waste rather than landfill and other
things because of the green agenda
is looking at waste for energy because i
think that's quite important going
forward with regard to our local plan i
may say
i i believe ethics are doing so in the
longer term
and some of the complexity around this
is that uh they are still contractually
obliged to use the mbt plants in basilan
at this time
um
not going into too much detail but yes
they are keen to look at different
options going forward
thank you
any other questions
no okay right
well as the recommendations here are set
out as a mixture of noting i'm going to
take them individually so that we go
through them and first of all
item
or point 1.1
under the decisions that the executive
notes the contents of the report
noted
1.2
that a budget
of 5 000 pounds be allocated as part of
the council's share in jointly
appointing external legal services to
finalize contract documents in
partnership
with bazilan and castle point borough
councils to deliver operationally
suitable residual waste arrangements
from the 1st of october 2021. can i ask
for a show of hands of those in favor
and that is unanimous
and moving on to 1.3 that the proposed
procurement route of open procedure with
a tender evaluation based on 90 percent
price
and 10 percent quality scoring criteria
be noted is that noted members
noted
and 1.4 that it be noted that the
recommendations for award of tender will
be presented to the executive in
september again is that noted members
noted
thank you
right we move on to item 10
section 106 quarterly briefing
july 2021
and that is to consider the report of
the assistant director place and
environment summarizing the council's
position on section 106 contributions as
at the first of july 2021
and uh council award are you going to
introduce it or do we go straight to
assistant director i will actually
introduce it thank you very much ladies
thank you council
i think this is a very very important
report because it really does emphasize
the fact that we are looking to audit
seriously the 106 money that we actually
collect
from various
how can i put it contributors
we have on there
those items that are selected for
ourselves that we will use and we have
the nhs the nhs is responsible for how
it collects and that's one of the things
that we will be
requiring and looking into
in the course of time with our officers
to ensure that that money is taken and
where it goes
there was a query that was
on this particular document which was
one of the last items saxon business
park in rochford
now before i actually bring any of
anything through we have some
announcements i believe that we'd like
to make on that and i'd like to hand
over
to mr hotton
who i believe
has some updates on that because it's
due on the first
of august 2021 which is quite imminent
sorry september
um
thank you
so uh we are um
actually uh in a meeting with south end
council so that they've actually drawn
up some plans um which they'd like to
take forward to
put in the cycle routes across across
the cherrywood way and so it's um just
in the nick of time in terms of the
budgets i think that they were keen to
see it being delivered rather than take
the money back so i think that there's a
genuine um
um kind of a spiritual cooperation
between the two of us
but um i'll be able to report back in a
little bit more detail on the matter to
portfolio holder of planning and the
world members i'm hoping next week but
what i understand is that there will be
a
um
a definite project put forward i believe
it's going to cost more than the hundred
thousand but um my understanding of
southern borough sounds are willing to
um pick up the uh the additional cost to
ensure that it's delivered
so um
in that sense the hundred thousand will
be um well spent if that makes sense
thank you
it does make sense thank you very much
indeed uh and i'm pleased about that
because the date bothered me a little
bit when i saw the first of september so
um and to hand back a hundred thousand
just didn't uh uh sit too comfortably
with me so i'm delighted to hear that
news that's uh that's that's good
um
right members any questions on the
report before you
no okay if there's no questions now all
i really want to say is and i'm i'm very
very pleased that council award
and um
the uh well that gave us all a surprise
and a shock didn't it and woke us up um
i'm extremely pleased that uh in
conjunction with the assistant director
council award has set out it makes it
look as if it's a regular quarterly
report but this is actually the first of
quarterly reporting on section 106
monies because i believe it is right
that quarterly we go through as part of
our regular governance where our section
106 monies
is
the progress and what is actually
happening to it the next stage of the
process
council award
is to make sure that following planning
agreements
we
go through a process to make sure that
members are kept fully up to speed with
the negotiation because my ambition is
that
106 money should rightly be spent within
our district
to enhance the benefit for
residents so often uh 106 monies can
be spirited away and we never quite know
where it's it's gone so i really welcome
this report delighted with its
production uh delighted it's going to
come back to us quarterly and any
questions in the intervening time i know
the assistant director will be delighted
to help members with thank you very much
indeed so
if with your agreement we move to the
decision um and that is simply that the
quarterly position on section 106
contributions held as at july 2021 be
noted we know that
i'm happy with that thank you very much
right return now to item number 11
which is the council projects program
management office
and
we're going to consider the report of
the acting managing director
providing an update on the connect
programme asset delivery program and the
beagle event program so i'm going to
turn to my left now to look to the
acting managing director thank you thank
you thank you councillor woodson this is
the uh regular quarterly report of the
council's pro projects program
management office
and the three projects that are within
its scope as you've identified the
connect program which is the council's
cultural and transformation programme
the asset development program and the
beagle event project
as set out in the report in terms of the
connect program we are we've made
significant progress around the early
stages
of the foundation and discovery phase
and that means that
officers within the council have
identified opportunities for
interventions that will improve
productivity and the digital outcomes
for customers
and to streamline services reduce
duplication and reduce manual handling
the next phase of the connect program
would be to bring
an investor to save proposition to this
executive
in september
and to ask this executive to make a
decision regarding the investment in
that business case
and that is intended to
center around a digital
implementation of a customer portal
which will allow
24 7 access to services via web
connectivity and to enable
customers therefore to access
transactional
business at any at their leisure and
without having to come through
the
customer services switchboard
the asset program as the asset delivery
program um continues as per its existing
program the two stop go decision points
um remain
programmed in for the autumn of this
year and for february of 2022
um following the feedback from the
public relating to the mill arts and
event center officers have been
reviewing the proposals with our
development partner that work is being
progressed and remains
subject to in the commercial negotiation
and when that work is complete
members it will be brought back to
council for further decision
in the meantime however we continue to
plan for
the program as it currently stands and
the decant subgroup has been set up to
lead the
key tasks for um timely handover in the
event that a decision is made to indeed
handover but of course that doesn't
prejudge or
determine any decision that the council
might make
the beagle project has
unfortunately
been a victim of the pandemic and was
due to take place as you know last year
under the current the restrictions have
also meant that it's
incapable of taking place this year um
we have uh spoken um
the portfolio holder for tourism and
myself about um reconfiguring the beagle
project for a date probably next year
and in coalition with
parish and town councils and i hope to
bring
some suggestions forward for that later
on in this calendar year
there's no nothing else further from me
um councillor wooden
thank you
members any questions
no okay
then we'll turn to
the decision being recommended
and it's a noting decision again at 1.1
in the report that updates being noted
on the council's three projects the
connect program
and the asset delivery program both gold
projects and the beagle event project a
silver project is that noted
thank you members
right we turn to item 12 which is
business rates right off
right we're going to consider the report
of the assistant director of resources
seeking approval to write off a sum in
respect of business rates
owed by bounce village limited
thank you council britain um yeah the
reports um hopefully is fairly
self-explanatory and i'm not intending
to
um go through it in detail but the
decision that's being recommended is
that the sum of 26 000 pounds
838 sorry 26
838 pounds and 50 pence in respect to
business rates owed by bounce village
limited
um at 12 a purdy ways rockford um is
written off
the council has exhausted all its
avenues um in terms of pursuing that
debt and the company is now in
insolvency proceedings
um and the council has been ranked as an
unsecured creditor um
in that
claim but is unlikely to um recover
those monies
um the council's
direct share of the write-off would be
ten thousand seven hundred and
thirty-five pounds and forty pence um
and the council has already made
provision for that
within its financial accounts so it
won't impact the general fund for this
financial year
so really i'm just looking for
executives approval for that decision
thank you thank you to naomi lucas
assistant director of resources thank
you
any questions before we move to a vote
nope okay well i will
move to the decision being recommended
at item 1
1.1
that the sum of 26
838 pounds 50 pence in respect of
business rates owed by bounce village
limited in respect of 12 a purdey's way
rochford is written off could i ask gray
show of hands in agreement
and that is unanimous
thank you we move then to
item 13 which is
again business rates right off and we
turn once again to the assistant
director of resources naomi lucas
thank you council whitson so this report
is um similar in nature
um
so yeah the decision being recommended
is that a sum of 139
866 pounds and 11 pence in outstanding
business rates is written off in respect
to the rate payer known as ks rochford
again the council has explored all its
avenues
in terms of pursuing that debt and has
engaged with specialist legal advice to
ensure that we
have tried to recover that but
unfortunately there doesn't appear to be
um a way that we will recover those
monies now
um
again the council's share of that
write-off would be 40 which equates to
55 000 pounds
sorry 55
946 pounds and 44 pence um and again
it's been provided for within the
council's account so there will be no
direct impact on the general fund for
this financial year
um so again i was seeking executive
approval for that write-off
thank you very much indeed naomi again
any questions
no
we go to decision being recommended at
1.1 that the sum of one hundred and
thirty nine thousand eight hundred and
sixty six pounds eleven pence in
outstanding business rates is written
off in respect of the great player known
as k stroke s rochford
and i have a show of hands please in
agreement
and again that is unanimous thank you
members
right members of the public um
first of all my very sincere thanks to
you all for coming here this evening uh
we've come to the end of the business
that we can debate with you at present
uh the remaining report and there is
just one further item uh contains exempt
information and i would therefore ask
that you now leave the meeting
but before i you actually leave the
meeting uh i will just put that formally
to members just to make sure that we're
not
respectfully asking you to leave and all
members vote against asking you to leave
but
it is hereby resolved and we're talking
about item 14 here
it is hereby resolve that under section
100a
four of the local government act 1972
the public be excluded from the meeting
for the following item of business on
the grounds that it involves the likely
disclosure of exempt information as
defined in paragraph one of part one of
schedule 12a of the act is that agreed
members
agreed
right at that point i'm afraid i've got
to ask you to to leave
just for the point of clarity other
members may stay
members may stay
adrian
okay
right we turn to
item number 15 um yeah everyone's gone
item number 15
and that's business rates and council
tax write-off
to consider the exempt report of the
assistant director of resources in
respect of writing offer some in respect
of business rates and council tax and
return once again
i believe to you
know me as assistant
director resources naomi
thanks again council whitton um
yeah again this report is similar to the
previous two the difference being that
it relates to an individual member of
the public so that's the reason it's
been taken in private and confidential
um
there is two amounts that are being
sought to be written off in respect to
that individual
firstly 47
612 pounds and 77 pence in respect to
business rates and also 13
849 pounds and 33 pence in respect of
council tax
these
amounts relates to
a mr hamish mummy um
who um has accrued these
debts over the period 11th december 2011
to the 8th of april 2020.
again the council has made all
reasonable efforts to try and recover
those amounts but has unfortunately been
unsuccessful
so again the council's share of the
business rates element will be 40
which equates to
1945 pounds and 10 pence
and the council's share of the council
tax element will be
1731 pounds and 16 pence
and again these amounts have been
provided for within the council's
accounts
and there will be no direct impact on
the general fund for this financial year
um
so again seeking executives approval
thank you
thank you naomi um any questions from
members of the executive council ft
manager
so essentially um we we could keep them
as on on our balance sheet as a you know
a debt owing to the council um and just
kind of postpone that for a future date
but it wouldn't go away it would just um
sort of carry on sitting there and
definitely until such time as we've
recovered the money or
chose to write it off but i i think it's
reasonable for the council after this
amount of time and the efforts it's
taken to make that decision to write it
off i was otherwise
we just end up building up a more and
more bad debt which obviously then has
to has an impact at some future date
a very good question councillor fd um
um right no other questions no we will
turn to decision being recommended at
item 1 1.1 that the sum of 47 612 pounds
77 pence in respect to business rates
and the sum of 13
849 pounds 33 pence in respect of
council tax are written off
members can i have a show of hands
please
if you agree and you do agree
so that's unanimous
members at 8 25 that completes the
business for the executive meeting
tonight
can i thank you for your attendance
can i thank visiting members for their
attendance can i thank officers for
their attendance and now i'm going to
spoil the show because i am actually
it's the first time that executive
members and senior officers have been
able to actually get together